ce cimetière compte de nombreuses tombes
récente
les civils qui avaient été enterrés dans
leur jardin par leurs voisins ont depuis
été déplacé ici
ils ont été tués le 12 mars nous les
avons enterré le 14 à un mètre de
profondeur
comment sont ils meurent
ils leur ont attaché les mains dans le
dos les ont mis à genoux elles auront
tiré par la tête l'un d'eux a eu le
visage arrachée
selon les habitants les russes
s'attendait à être reçus en libérateurs
naturel et vieux au début leur politique
était de ne pas toucher aux civils mais
ensuite ils se sont rendus compte que
tous les habitants étaient contre eux
alors ils ont commencé à nous considérer
tous comme des ennemis touche
andré est ici pour entretenir les
vieilles tombes familiales une tradition
de pâques en ukraine il fait une pause
pour nous faire visiter le village
papalia des mines non non il y en a pas
ici
ça c'est l'ancienne ferme collective les
russes étaient basés là
cette zone est miné il tirait des
mortiers sur les maisons à partir de là
la famille s'estime chanceuse partie
après une semaine de bombardements elle
a retrouvé sa maison pillée mais intacte
un éclat d'obus a atterri ici
heureusement la maison n'a pas brûlé
elle est en bois dont qu'il y avait un
risque d' incendies mais dieu merci ça
ne s'est pas produit
mais de l'autre côté de la rue
c'est beau tout est brûlé il ne reste
rien tetiana est resté ici durant toute
l'occupation
d'abord dans sa cave puis chez un voisin
elle raconte que les soldats russes
étaient souvent ivre est hors de
contrôle
il y a eu beaucoup de cas de viols et de
tortures
l'un des russes m'a dit votre village
riche vous avez des voitures importées
et de l'électroménager pas nous
qui vous a autorisé à vivre si bien
novembre et les chaînes classiques
non loin de la chaire et récupère du
matériel de sa maison en construction
elle a été squattée par les soldats
russes
c'est pénible je n'ai plus envie d'en
ménager je ne veux même pas finir le
travail
comment at il survécu
il cherchait surtout des vétérans de
l'armée ukrainienne dans le donbass
il confiera ensuite être lui-même un
vétéran du dombass il a juste eu la
chance de ne pas avoir été démasqué